[Music]
North Korea's leader Kim Jong-un
received a typically enthusiastic
welcome from party members in Pyongyang
but the overall mood of the meeting was
somber
North Korea's failed attempt to launch
its first spy satellite into space last
month was described as the greatest
failure officials in charge of the
mission were criticized and ordered to
prepare for another launch as quickly as
possible there are foresture critics of
its own failure is a clear reflection of
anxiety and concern inside a ruling
party and the Republic because North
Korea needs to continuously develop
weapons of mass destruction in order to
prepare for the event eventual
negotiations with Washington
South Korea detected last month's launch
from North Korea's main Space Center the
U.S says it involved ballistic missile
technology which goes against U.N
resolutions
the rocket crashed into the sea shortly
after takeoff in South Korea's military
salvaged sum of the projectile analysts
say this is what's most worrying North
Korea the reflects a deep concern about
South Korea United States Japan learning
the in and out of the North Korea's ICBM
technology so if these three countries
will have a clear understanding of where
North Korea's ICBM capability exists
then it will greatly undermines the
bargaining leverage of North Korea
party meetings such as this are normally
annual events this is the third this
year members were told Pyongyang plans
to strengthen relationships with
countries opposing U.S strategies
including China and is determined to
continue developing nuclear weapons
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera